with spikes a large metal ball floats in
istanbul's bus first straight
it's a sea mine built by the former
soviet union turkish commandos approach
it carefully the team will defuse the
device and then remove it
it's the second time in three days
turkish fishermen have found a mine like
this in their waters
last week russia's main intelligence
agency said 420 floating mines had
drifted into the black sea after
breaking up from cables near ukrainian
ports because of a storm ukraine denied
these claims it says russia planted the
mines
a former turkish rear admiral jihadi
says the tides and wind are diverting
the mines towards istanbul he believes
the mines belong to ukraine
it would be illogical for russia to mine
ports in odessa where it's aiming for a
military landing why would they shoot
themselves also if these mines broke off
so easily it means the mining wasn't
done properly that makes one think the
mines were left to float free in the
black sea
international law allows states to lay
sea mines in their waters to protect
themselves from attack but allowing
mines to float into international waters
is illegal
the u.n should be questioning ukraine
turkey has a strong capacity to sweep
the mines but this is an irresponsible
act
no matter who was responsible for the
mines they now pose a serious risk to
local fishermen like shaheen who have
been told not to fish at night
shahin says when turkey diffused the
mines in the sea last week the explosion
hit like an earthquake
if you don't see the mine then you
explode you're done only a slight
contact is enough to do it night fishing
is banned now thank god it's the end of
the season but if we were in peak season
then the scenario would be different
we're expecting many more mines to drift
by here in a month or so
the black sea is a major shipping artery
for grain oil and oil products turkish
trades are the only waterways trying it
to the mediterranean and the asian seas
38 000 vessels passed through the strait
of istanbul last year any interruption
or risk in this region could disrupt the
global supply chain
at this time it is not clear who is
responsible for these mines or how many
of them are floating out there posing a
threat to people and marine life unless
these questions are answered it may take
years to spot and disable these
explosive devices in the black sea sinam
kyo solo al jazeera istanbul